amid growing concerns about violence
against Christians recent upsurge in
spitting and hitting attacks on clergy
and the vandalism of Christian sit
greetings of peace I have an extremely
important question to ask a certain
group of Christians should Christians
support the state of Israel in the first
five minutes he was spat at five times
and before I do I need every Christian
to watch
[Music]
this
we don't you
go we don't you
go we
don't W okay you watched that by the way
on your own time you can watch there are
many more videos like this now let's do
one more clip it's of a Christian Pastor
then I'm going to bring out my Christian
guest Israel should make the Gaza Strip
a parking lot by this time next
week destroy the whole thing I'm sick of
all these Christians saying we ought to
have peace with Islam Islam is a satanic
death call and they would cut your head
off before I said amen in this sermon if
they had a chance to all right so I want
you guys to remember those clips because
my questions are going to revolve around
those clips with my next guest Allison
Weir she's from if Americans remember
this website if Americans only knew she
independently traveled throughout the
West Bank the Gaza Strip Mrs Weir found
the situation largely the reverse of
what was being reported by the American
Media upon further examination of the
issues at hand she read dozens of books
on the topic she found that the US press
portrayal was significantly
significantly at odds with information
being reported by the mainstream media
throughout the rest of the world so
without further Ado let's bring out our
special guest Allison Weir
the I love you you're do when I was
ready to talk about it I would only talk
to I was explaining how much respect I
have for the
of to
the
the hello Allison how are you I'm good
thank you how are you good good thank
you for coming back on the program it's
good to see you good to have you with us
thank you all right I'm going to open up
with this question
Allison to us Muslims this seems like a
very strange relationship on one end you
have Christians being spit at told to go
back home on the other end you have
Christian pastors who are supposed to be
preaching Peace Love Mercy forgiveness
Jesus the prince of peace turn the other
cheek love your neighbor but instead
they're supporting the killing of babies
they're encouraging their congregations
to basically throw away their money in
supporting this it's ve it's very
strange relationship if you can help us
understand the rationale the logic
behind this I'd be glad to
um largely there are a number of things
that are behind it you know I've been
working on this issue for 20 years now
after I traveled over to the West Bank
in Gaza in early 2001 as a freelance
reporter and saw for myself what was
going on um I was non some tour
conducted by Palestinians or by Israelis
most Christians that go over there
um go on to is conducted by by Israel so
they're shown certain things and not
shown other things it's very important
to go
independently many Christians have so
others besides me have actually also
seen what's going on but most of us
don't have the ability to do that and so
most people in the United States on all
the issues that are important in our
country rely on the US media for our
information and think we know what's
going on from that
information uh I think many of us know
if we're liberals we don't trust the
conservative media if we're conservative
media we don't trust the liberal media
most of us don't know that neither type
of media is reliable on the issue of
Israel Palestine that there's a great
deal mainly of omission and
exaggeration so for example the recent
um attacks on Israel on October 7th I
believe it was was that got so much
attention um mainly Americans we got the
Israeli narrative the US journalists
over there were shown around by Israeli
forces by the Israeli military they umed
briefings by the Israeli military
spokesperson and there were a lot of
exaggerations made at the beginning and
since that have since proven to be false
but most some of them were retracted
later but most people don't know they
were retracted
so that that Pastor that we just saw in
his congregation no doubt believed that
Hamas had beheaded babies this is
completely untrue anybody that looks
into it independently sees that that
accusation has
withdrawn um they with through that they
were beheaded but they said dozens of
babies were killed no that's another
thing that was false um so there are
atrocity stories as we know from
previous Wars World War I the Huns were
eating um you know babies supposedly and
you know there each War has its own
propaganda and Israel has a great deal
of propaganda about what it does all the
time and unfortunately the media often
just transcribe that propaganda as
though it's news so a lot of people are
being misled about what's going on and
it's not just about October 7th this is
successful because it goes on
top of years and years of misinformation
from the US media on this issue now and
then there are very good articles but
quite often even the articles that seem
like they're balanced and neutral and um
objective almost always have pro-israel
spin in them when you actually know what
went on and some article many many
reports are far worse than that they're
exaggerating the Israeli claims and
they're omitting major facts so
Americans don't know what's going on for
example they don't know that
Palestinians in Gaza the gazans men
women and children over two million of
them are living in largely a
prison there are only a few exits and
entrances to Gaza I think it's about two
or three I've been in gone through two
of them myself these are closed off by
armed guards
this is what it's like if you wanted to
leave you know Michigan or Arkansas or
California or you know and there are
armed guards around where you let you
could only leave certain places because
there's a fortified barrier around Gaza
that was built beginning in about
1991 and become more more fortified over
the years so you cannot get out unless
Israeli armed guards let you out you
have to get special permission from
Israel to leave your own land they
usually don't give it and even to get
back in you have to get permission to
get back in it's a prison to the extent
that Americans have no idea and within
that prison people have been deprived of
sufficient food for for a long time um
they've been deprived of a lot of
important building materials often
medical supplies can't get in there was
a time probably of course now but even
before the recent actions there were
insufficient
[Music]
um uh life-saving medicines were not
available because they weren't allowed
in
so the desperation for those two million
people inside that prison has been
growing over the
years also people need to know that
about 80 70 to 80% probably 80% of the
people living in Gaza those families in
Gaza are people that were pushed out by
Israel in 1948 and
49 that were originally from what we now
call
Israel um their land their homes their
businesses were all stolen and they were
forced out of there and most most of
them they went up different places but a
great many of them ended up in Gaza so
now the gazan population are people who
are living quite often in poverty
because of this a blockade Israel that's
been going on um over 17 years they're
living in poverty because of Israeli
actions they're living in a prison
because Israel is keeping them there and
and yet they were prosperous originally
you know people my age when I was born
there wasn't any Israel there was
Palestine the war of founding War which
was very
brutal took it over and named it Israel
so the people in Gaza
are living under conditions no American
could tolerate either but Americans
don't know that American Christians most
of them unless they've studied this
independently and gone there
independently and researched it for
themselves don't know it any of these
facts they just get the facts that
Israel puts out and our Us Media just
Echo and repeat too
often I think that's one of the major
factors they um
then the other thing is that there is a
theology that began called it's often
called dispensationalism there's a type
of theology that was dispensation
dispensationalism yes most of us okay
yes you know have never heard of when I
was growing up nobody ever I was in a
military family so I had moved around a
lot I attended churches in a number of
different states and sometimes on
Military basis and I never even heard
this
dispensationalism it was developed in
the late in the um mid to late 1800s by
a sort of obscure sect within England
the Brethren it was called something
like that um the Plymouth Brethren
Plymouth Brethren very few you know you
know about it but most Americans don't
know about it so I didn't know about it
till I studied it and you know thought
where did this come from what came from
an obscure sect you know ones like that
around today that have different
theologies that you know don't have many
adherence but but they're
around this one wouldn't have been very
widespread except it was taken up by a
man named Cyrus scoffield who was a
pastor in I believe it was
Texas um a very sketchy man he was he
had abandoned his wife and children I
believe he was even in prison for a
while for um yeah some
scams that he was
running but he grew to be influential
and he wrote a book called The annotated
scoffield bi reference Bible
that has been began to be used in a lot
of Bible colleges and in different many
people apparently have that Bible I have
a copy of it somewhere I never had seen
it before but that became very
influential now the thing that's
interest so that's largely what spread
this
dispensationalism what's interesting is
that the Bible was published by the
Oxford University press which is not the
usual place where a Texas preacher would
be able to get his Bible you know his um
his own annotated Bible published so his
his biographer named Mr Canfield I've
forgotten his first name if you read the
biography which everybody should of
Cyrus scoffield you find out all these
things that I'm saying but you also find
out that the biographer writes that it
seems likely somebody else was behind
scoffield funding him and giving him the
access to people and places he would not
have had
otherwise the biographer notes that he
was a member of a Manhattan literary
club now again is this where you know a
Christian minister
especially Evangelical Minister would be
member of a Manhattan literary Club but
he was he was also at that time was a
man named Samuel unterm who was a very
powerful um Jewish attorney in Manhattan
I think he was the first people to
receive a you know $1 million award at a
time and that's probably worth $1
million today maybe more and he was a
fervent Israel partisan working very
hard to create the state of Israel which
did not exist yet this was in the very
early 1900s but he was part of this
movement that most of us have never
heard of political Zionism that was very
active in the in Europe and in the
United States not in the region um the
Jewish people that were living in
Palestine at that time were actually
opposed to this political
Zionism but Samuel ANM
was a powerful part of the movement he
was in that literary Club at the same
time that scoffield was and people the
biographer suggests and to me this makes
a great deal of sense that it was UNM
and his wealth that opened doors for for
scoffield to produce a Bible that was
very useful for the Zionist project of
taking over Palestine to creating to
create a Jewish
state a lot wow this is
um excuse me I was just going to mention
at the time that it was published there
were a number of very uh reputable and
respected theologians at the time I
think uh Evangelical theologians who
were
who um wrote books exposing the fact
that that this reference Bible was just
not accurate that had misinformation in
it that was not to be trusted so this
was written at the time but when as we
all know in this world if you have lots
of money you can push your
message um there are Evangelical
fundamentalist Christians who have been
very supportive of the Palestinian cause
for many decades but they didn't get a
jet plane given to them as Jerry fwell
was so that he could go around saying
what Israel wanted him to say and
somebody like Ted price who was one of
the I think he and his father were
behind the National Prayer day doesn't
have a jet plane and people never hear
from
him
so I think this is um answering the
question what you just broke down I
asked the question also I had a pastor
on Pastor um a senior pastor he's been
around for a long time Pastor Rick and
he pretty much went over in detail how
this pre dis dispensationalism
which is pretty much Zion
Zionism packaged into Christian
Creed and he went over the similar
things you're talking about so now it
helps us understand where many
Christians are torn between seeing
babies just being decapitated and bombs
falling on innocent human beings and now
why would they align with this but they
think because as Pastor Rick was telling
me and we're understanding from you also
this they've been indoctrinated through
this coners skolfield in this Bible that
was funded by this certain ideology in
there that now connects certain verses
of the Bible to this modern state of
Israel and from there they made it a
part of the Christian Creed that
Christians feel this is a part of their
theology some Christian they're sinful
some Christians some Christians yes
absolutely yes some Christians feel that
this is a part of their Creed is that
cor they're sinful so I think this is
very important that we unpackage this so
Christians can see this is not a part of
their Creed this is fake they're trying
to push there's some prophecies also
that revolve around this that they're
trying to come uh to fulfill is this
correct that's right there that when I
ask Pastor there certain if you can talk
about that certain Chris you know
scriptures that they're trying to
emphasize and incorrectly interpret and
ignore all the rest of the New Testament
it's sort of you know it's it's very
it's laughable except it's very
dangerous and very sad and causing major
destruction not only tragedy in Israel
Palestine but it is causing great damage
to our own country I have eight
grandchildren and I I feel they're
exposed to um risk by what Israel is
doing and the fact that our government
is funding it um but getting back to
this theology just to mention also so
you know this was the root of it it
still goes on that that so-called
reference Bible keeps being republished
every few years and actually gets worse
and worse
interestingly and then also on top of
that you have a group called supposedly
Christians United for Israel kufi yes
and Pastor heggy that promote this you
know they're very very to me
anti-christian very pro-israel with a
large Congregation of probably very
decent people who are being misled and
don't know just to give a little bit of
the back on I them a lot all of this is
on our website if Americans knew
but for example they don't mention that
the person who really founded Christians
United for Israel who was the executive
director for many years of that
organization was a man named David brog
who was as a Jewish attorney who
practiced law in Tel
Aviv um and who has
been major the the major force behind
supposedly Christians United for Israel
the current exec executive director is
listed in Israel as the 50 most
influential Jews in the world this is
behind
kofy um the action director is another
is an Israeli citizen so you know people
need to look into things more closely
and see who's really pulling the strings
behind the scenes
I think many people are scared to look
into things because they're scared to be
labeled they're scared um being
cancelled but we've had rabbis on we've
had Christians we've had people
good-hearted people who who don't agree
with this and they're speaking out and
more people are beginning to speak out
because Christians don't want this to
represent them and their faith and now I
think it's even more important when they
see this is not a credle thing this
they're not sinful for not supporting
this like there's verses in the Bible
and this is what P the the Christians
that I spoke to uh including the pastor
you could tell me what what would you
agree that these verses for example
whoever blesses thee will be blessed
whoever curses thee will be cursed
you'll see politicians and others who
will hold the flag and and quote this
verse and they'll connect this to the
state and when when I asked the I asked
the pastor he says no this is bogus this
is not
correct uh that's right what would you
say it's not it's have you are you
familiar are you familiar with the verse
that's this is like the bread and butter
yes yes I I've looked into it um first
of all it's often really not translated
correctly it's not referring to the
modern state of Israel um it's talking
to the you know many people that feel
that the Old Testament there was a you
know there was a new testament these
Christians need to remember that there
was a new testament and in that
Testament um it was it taught very
differently than what's in the Old
Testament and that with the coming of
that the chosen people became all people
not just one particular ethnic group so
you know just read the New Testament for
yourself and what it taught and that
pretty much refutes taking a few a few
little pieces of it out of
context um I found that's interesting is
that even people that were brought up
with that I you know
clearly um misunderstood theology when
they go and see in person what's going
on when they re meet Palestinians both
Palestinian Muslims and Palestinian
Christians that's another thing that the
media largely prevent Americans from
knowing is that many Palestinians are
Christians that they've live you know
they live side by side with Muslim
neighbors and colleagues and co-workers
have done this for many years they're
Christians in Gaza itself Israel you
know and it's shelling recently damaged
at least two Christian churches in Gaza
one of them the one of the most ancient
Christians in Christian churches in the
world was damaged by Israeli
shelling so you
know you can you know that's that's a
very important Point what you just said
there are also Christians there who are
being persecuted and oppressed what is
it like 10% or more are Christians
Palestinian Christians it's a small
number they keep fleeing because of
Israel so that um yes the it's you know
Bethlehem has been closed off by by
Israel for many years there are
incursions into Israel into Bethlehem
itself where people are beaten
frequently um young people young men
especially are abducted this goes on in
Bethlehem if you go to our website and
see some of our reports every day there
are Christian sites that are damaged and
invaded by Israeli forces frequently
frequently and it's documented if you're
there you can see them
firsthand um just people when I showed
that when I oh go ahead finish your
thought what were you gonna say that's
fine when I opened up the program I
wanted to strike
an image that people can understand like
because if you have there you have the
people who are supporting like this
pastor also in the second clip
supporting this and then he would be
someone who' go down there and he would
also be we have uh undercover reports
where people would dress up as a priest
and be spit at like five times and
recently Israeli Channel 13 reporter
Yosi Ellie went under cover as a priest
for a day dressed in a robe he walked
through the old city with Franciscan
father Alberto in the first 5 minutes he
was spat at five times by Orthodox
Jewish Israelis Christian citizens feel
attacked in their places of Prayer in
their cemeteries and on the streets
Christians in Jerusalem's Old City say
they are often harassed spit on and even
physically attacked by religious Jewish
youth that's the ironic thing how you
can go ahead and support something like
this but then there's a great disrespect
happening like is showing in this clip
towards not only the Palestinian
Christians down there but even
Evangelical Christians who have visited
um that's right is this something that
you've Evangelical Christians have been
strip searched you know by Israeli um
guards they're you know they're you know
often they're treated quite well because
they want to propagandize them but you
know not always they get strip searched
um they get there you know there's a
they get spat upon that's not rare
there's um a certain aspects of Judaism
to be to be truthful are very
anti-christian I'm not saying all
Israelis are most Israelis I think
probably are not we give them over $10
million a day
so but um there are shows on Israeli TV
in you know mainstream Israeli TV making
fun of Jesus in really very offensive
ways those are you know you can I think
we've put some clips on so there's been
um Christian churches making fun making
fun of making fun of Jesus Jesus Christ
yes of Mary please be upon um really
grotesque shows just you know laughing
at them and dressing people up in weird
ways so
that's the strange relationship that I
if you can help us understand and I
guess you did with the explanation of
the scoffield Bible this con artist who
put this together and then who it was
funded by so I guess would you say that
this would be the reason and then these
pastors who are promoting this according
to this and they're funded by this that
now they've been fooled and they've been
indoctrinated with this false belief and
that this is a part of their care this
kind of information is is just not
available to people they have no idea
this is going on um that's a major part
of it so you know people are
manipulated what would you say to our
Christian friends and neighbors and
others who are listening to you as a as
a Christian now what advice would you
give them who they they feel strongly
this is you know you hear Rapture I I I
spoke to the pastor about this also he
said we we believe in Jesus's return
like we do as Muslims but they push this
that he'll return twice
this is not a Biblical teaching he said
and and much of this this this Rapture
um theology if you want to comment on
that he said also this is something
that's made up and a lot of people
believe this what advice would you give
to them well to you to look into it more
fully to go to you know more more
theologians I'm not one so I'm not going
to pretend that I am yeah but I think
there's a lot of when you want to find
the truth when you want to find the
truth in this day and age you can it's
there and there um I mean what's
interesting is that many denominations
now have made statements in support of
Palestinian rights because they know the
facts about what's going on in Palestine
they've traveled there independently
they've met with Palestinian Christians
and Muslims they've seen firsthand
What's Done sometimes there there have
been non I think Americans again don't
know that there have been nonviolent
demonstrations virtually every week
sometimes two or three a week for many
years often in in small villages by you
know just normal people those lands are
being taken by by Israel I've seen them
I've been in them and the Israeli
military comes along and beats people
and you know uh meets them with violence
these are unarmed villagers that are
beaten and nobody ever you know they do
this it's very courageous just because
in a number of cases people are shot
sometimes they're killed a few have been
Americans whove been killed or named but
of course most of them are Palestinians
and the the the power of nonviolence for
example with Gandy with Martin Luther
King is that people see it they see
people
non-violently trying to demonstrate for
their rights or against
Injustice and that's the power then when
they're met with violence and people see
it they are horrified well Palestinians
have been doing this for years years
under great risk that they will
be injured maimed killed and yet they
still do it but the American public
which is funding Israel doesn't see it
Fox News doesn't ever cover it CNN
rarely if ever covers it MS NBC doesn't
cover it so NPR doesn't cover it so this
has been going on for for years and then
finally on 2000 in 2018 the people in
Gaza in this prison decided that they
would try a huge huge gandhian
nonviolent march called the Great March
of return thousands of people came
together every
week near the the barrier imprisoning
them men women and children there you
know it was announced ahead of time you
could see people Gathering and there's
the women's March everybody was very
excited that they were going to do this
and the world would see it and finally
they would stop they would get on their
rights their children would be able to
prosper and Israel deployed snipers and
shot a number of them the very first day
they did this every week for almost two
years it was over a year year and a half
about a year and twoth thirds or
something they did this every week
thousands of them they were you know
many people were shot every day now
there are people children with amputated
limbs there are people you know not only
are the killed people but the people
that have have lifelong injuries and
America week after week after week by
what supposedly our Ally that gets over
10 million dollars per day of our tax
money and Americans don't even know it
went
on
wow I want to show one more clip from
this pastor and ask my next question
before we conclude I'm sick of all these
Christians saying we ought to have peace
with Islam Islam is a satanic death cult
and they would cut your head off before
I said amen in this sermon if they had a
chance to did you ever feel you got to
hear that right yeah did you ever feel
you travel to Gaza the West Bank you
know when um people that don't get out
of their home
Hometown and they don't travel they
don't mix uh besides just you know the
community that they're around and then
they hear something like this from this
pastor I think is very very dangerous
yeah because he's painting a picture
he's painting a picture like if a Muslim
gets a chance he's going to chop your
head off did you at any time feel that a
danger did you feel your life was
threatened because you're a Christian
and you were around some Muslims never I
was you know the first time I went as I
said was February March of 2001 I
wandered around by myself with my
notebook and little camera went around
Gaza by myself walking around um know I
was invited to stay in people's homes
which I was glad to do uh I was never it
was actually very safe people invite
hold on people people invited you to
stay in their home did they know you
were those cousins or brothers or
no I don't have any any relatives that
are Palestinian or
um no this was just they were so happy
were these like really were were these
were these like very rich people that
they had huge mansions that they're
inviting you in their homes um most were
not but one was one had actually a very
nice home um but even that you know they
but most weren't you know they were just
random people that would would meet me
and were very you know when I would go
around I was in hunas for example that's
you know talked about if you watch the
news a lot I was in Gaza City I was in
Rafa and people would come up to me you
know crowds of people because there were
no other Americans This was at the
height of the second Uprising called the
second
inata um and they would come up and just
say say hello because they you know a
lot of people it's like if somebody
French came we all say bonjour even if
we didn't speak French but there a
number of people that do speak English
that's taught in the schools so you know
they would they were happy to have me
there and would want to show me what was
going on to their homes they take me in
and show me how bullet riddled they
were um and then they would ask me to
tell Americans about them which I told
them I would do and that's why I'm still
doing it now I went back on other trips
one time with my daughter we traveled
around we couldn't get into Gaza because
they've kept it closed off I I went into
got into Gaza one time since but we went
around the West Bank that's also being
you know also
under daily attacks by Israeli forces
thought ver and we were never at any
risk um this is just there was another
thing there's so much you know this is
20 years worth of I could talk for weeks
but um there was even in about 2003
there was a group this is well
documented a number of Israel partisans
and groups came together to
intentionally create
islamophobia that they would promote
anti-muslim um feeling around the United
States and who is that this was um it's
written about it's actually there's an
article about it on the let me see if I
can bring it up I I think believe so it
was well funded by um can't remember the
name let me just look this up the pastor
I was talking to he was kind of alluding
to the same thing that this was
orchestrated this was set up to plant
this in the of Americans This Hate of
Muslims and Islam to create this
division between Christians and Muslims
that's right this has been going on by a
number of people and again it's it's
documented this I don't believe in
conspiracy theories I want to confir
neither I don't have time for it that's
right I want people if if any
conservatives do watch this they know
how often the media is slanted against
that portion of our population there's a
lot of
misinformation about what conservatives
have done so they should realize that
that same kind of misinformation and
twisting and Omission is going on about
Palestine you the media they they
trust are not trustworthy on the
Palestinian issue almost you know very
few of none of the mainstream ones that
I've seen really do have good coverage
of it even though they often had
accurate accurate coverage on other
things so conservatives have also often
been called anti- if you work on
Palestine or if you're conservative you
will be called anti-semitic
falsely so they need to realize it's not
that you know don't don't believe that
accusation um so let me just see if I
can quickly get this information because
as I said people go to our website if
Americans new.org you can get all of
this but this is one of the main ones to
know about yeah I think this is very
very important when you have people who
are fueling this hate people who are in
the business of hate while we're trying
to spread understanding and that's what
our program is about helping people
understand to create tolerance to create
some kind of Peace that's right through
education that's right it's extremely I
think this is a very strong word and I
don't use it very often but it's it's
truly evil to try to create hatred to
try to make entire populations hate
other populations when most populations
are composed of decent human beings love
their children who want to live in
safety and peace that's true of all
populations including the Israeli
population and yet here you have
absolutely an effort a well-funded
effort to make Americans fear and hate
Muslims and they and they want the same
group wants Muslims to fear and hate
Christians absolutely like you said this
is evil yes so the groups that did this
and these aren't the only ones there's
step Emerson who's a supposedly
anti-terrorist um expert who's an Israel
partisan that goes
around creating that but then there's
this group that of was launched in
Earnest in
2003 um the meeting gave this was a
network this by the way the person who
wrote this particular article is a
Jewish person this is not anti-Semitic
but it's factual a network of Jewish
groups ranging from the ADL which calls
everybody they don't like anti-semitic
ranging from the ADL and the American
Jewish committee which is actually a
pro-israel organization that's its main
purpose um to APAC the American Israel
public affairs committee so those are
three of the groups that gather there
were others there also gathered to
address what they saw as a sudden rise
in Pro Palestinian activism ISM so the
meeting gave birth to this network to
create fear and hatred of
Muslims those three groups this is
documented this is and others wow
um then I'm just going to read they got
one of the people that was paying for it
because you know the more money you have
the more effective your propaganda is so
there was
um sorry I'm just trying to read this
quickly and I'm can't find his name it's
while you do that want to just show my
audience there'll be a clip of showing
you have former Israeli Personnel you
have also a former um intelligent person
showing how people how they use this
term anti-semitic they weaponize it so
you just keep searching and this is a
tactic and a ploy so I'll let them go
ahead and listen to this and of course
the campaign starts and before you know
it the guy's
labeled and he's an anti-em because
that's what we say he is and that's one
St you cannot
wash now it shames me as a Jew to tell
you that but that's the fact and it's
wrong that's right well I think if they
just Google this as we say these days
just there's something called the Great
islamophobic
Crusade it's on our website the great
Islam it's on your website if Americans
only knew they look for the great
Islamic that's right by the way um our
website our official name is if American
new if Americans new.org yes um yes what
was that uh the title again the great
islamophobic
Crusade oh the great islamophobic
Crusade this is just one of a number of
initiatives to okay to create my last
question here is go ahead you want to
add something else just there are a
number of initiatives this was one of
many to create anti-islam beliefs in the
United States
my last question is and I pose this
question to many Christians in the
pastor that I had on also I said do you
get offended as a Christian when I say
Jesus peace be upon Him does that offend
you I love
it you know we obviously love Jesus
that's the other thing that's so covered
up that that Jesus is revered by Muslims
that's people need to know that and they
don't they don't know that Mary is
feared by Muslims and yes we believe
Jesus was a messenger like Abraham like
Noah like like all the messengers who
came with the same message worship one
and only one God and be morally upright
so there's no disrespect of Jesus no um
hurtful things heed at his hurled at his
mother there's a whole chapter named
after his Blessed Mother in the Quran
and what what were you gonna
say I think just um that this is you
know there's
there are extremists everywhere so you
can find some extremist action by
chrisan you know look at that Pastor to
me that was you know really horrendous
extremism but he doesn't represent all
pastors he doesn't even represent all
the pastors that might believe that
theology you know most them would not be
that horrible or that
bloodthirsty so absolutely
yes so uh it's been a great session
again thank you uh for coming on thank
you God bless you thank you thank you to
you and that's Allison we with with if
Americans
new.org thanks very
much thank you thank you Alon I cannot
leave without giving you a gift if
you're not yet Muslim and you're tuning
in to see what these Muslims are talking
about and you like a free copy of the
Quran go ahead and visit theen show.com
we'll take care of the postage and
everything and get it delivered to you
and if you still have some questions
about Islam call us at 18006 62 4752
we'll see you next time until then peace
be with
you I'm drad and I'm so excited to be
here at the dean Center mallah which is
under renovation and I can't wait to see
what's going to come inshallah there's
going to be a dawa Center there's a
Masjid there's a school an Islamic
school a gym and what we hope inshallah
will also have a mental health part of
this Center as well inallah so I'm
asking you to please make sure that you
support this effort inshallah I really
hope that it spreads and really the
knowledge of Islam and people get to
know more about Muslims and Islam
through this
[Music]
effort